let's go next to Shelley from Indiana
Shelly welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
how are you I'm doing well
um
question is about the Trump
Administration sure a lot of times uh
during and after you would hear Trump
supporters say uh about all of his
accomplishments but when you would ask
them what are they a common response is
well I'm not going to tell you you need
to do your own research sometimes I mean
sometimes they will Shelly generally say
well look he did the economy and he cut
regulations and he dealt with all these
great you know he dealt with countries
and he fixed the Border you know they'll
just say things that aren't true that's
another possibility
well and my so my question was were
there any major accomplishments in the
Trump Administration
that
that you could actually point to well I
there's a couple of a couple things I
mean I think that the first step Act and
the Criminal Justice Reform that he did
um
contained some positive initiatives to
some degree you know it's not a reason
to elect the guy but he did kind of
stumble I think thanks to some of the
people that were around him into a
couple of uh modest improvements there I
think that Trump's tax plan
lowering the Threshold at which medical
expenses become deductible was was a
good thing you know the tax plan overall
was a disaster uh you know I mean it's
like I can find a couple little things
here and there
okay
um yeah that was it I just
um I I hear a lot from people that oh
you know people on the left they don't
they don't want to notice
accomplishments when when there's a
republican in
yeah no listen I mean I'm glad to
acknowledge accomplishments if that's
really what they are but a lot of times
it's just it they're not really
accomplishments you know what what do
you think his biggest accomplishment was
I don't know of it you don't know yeah I
mean it's tough to think of them all
right Shelly things are okay in Indiana
they're not too insane
nice so it's going well I live in the in
the Northern America so all right Flags
over here Shelly you're breaking up a
little bit but it sounded like you said
not too many Trump Flags where you are I
really appreciate the call okay
hey thank you all right there is Shelley
from Indiana the internet tubes must not
be super wide there which is why we were
having an issue I'm going to take a very
quick break if you are holding
don't hang up because I'm going right
back to the phones in a moment